[Music]
which would you prefer
eternal life or unlimited wealth how
about both for that you need the
Philosopher's Stone a substance that can
turn base Metals into gold and Grant you
eternal life The Book of Aquarius
contains the instructions for the
Philosopher's Stone now although the
process can take years the ingredients
are simple you have them in your home
right now but the Book of Aquarius is
derived from many older texts including
one very mysterious artifact the Emerald
Tablet which contains not only the
recipe for immortality but the secret to
everything in the universe this
knowledge has been around for centuries
but has been suppressed until now
medieval Alchemists receive this
knowledge from the Arabs a thousand
years ago the Arabs got it from the
Egyptians 2 000 years before that but
the Egyptians received this knowledge 36
000 years ago from the most advanced
culture on Earth the Emerald Tablet
comes from Atlantis
foreign
for hundreds of years the recipe for the
Philosopher's Stone was the most sought
after secret of alchemy according to
Legend this substance could turn
ordinary metals like lead and iron into
gold the Philosopher's Stone was also
called The Elixir of life because it
could restore Youth and even Grant
immortality for centuries Alchemists
attempted to create the stone breaking
down distilling and combining different
materials in pursuit of this goal this
actually led to the creation of
chemistry now this might sound like
Hocus Pocus but some of the most
Brilliant Minds in history believed in
the Philosopher's Stone and dedicated a
large portion of their lives in pursuit
of it some became so infatuated that it
drove them to the brink of insanity
Isaac Newton is remembered for his
contributions to mathematics astronomy
and physics but he was also interested
in alchemy Newton spent the last 30
years of his life obsessed with the
Philosopher's Stone he even made his own
translations of the Emerald Tablet which
are still studied today Holy Roman
Emperor Rudolph II brought the best
Alchemists in Europe to court men like
John D and Edward Kelly were given a
private lab and an unlimited budget at
the beginning of the Renaissance there
was an alchemist who as the legend goes
actually discovered the Philosopher's
Stone and his name was Nicholas palmell
now he gave it to Dumbledore what well
actually puts it and bring its fault and
then Hagrid fetched it for him I don't
think that's what wants it because he's
stuck in it back in queero's head right
didn't Hermione get some past the devil
snare and then Rod plays Wizard's Chest
by the way he used the names of which
defense as an opening Gambit you don't
see that much with Wizard's Chest
now if you believe in the legend or
Harry Potter Nicholas famel didn't die
in 1418. he succeeded in creating the
Philosopher's Stone and he and his wife
paranel are still alive and out there
somewhere whoa 600 years is a long time
to be married
I guess it is a long time
so so so so so so very long
a long time
ever since man realized that his life
was finite the human race has been
fascinated with the idea of extending
their lifespan or even achieving
immortality the legend of the Fountain
of Youth has been around for hundreds of
years and now we have cryonics which is
freezing a body at the moment of death
in the hope of Reviving them at some
point in the future or mind uploading
which will transfer a person's
Consciousness to a computer and then at
some point transfer that Consciousness
back into a human or part human part
robot body but it all started with the
Emerald Tablet written by the Egyptian
God jihoodi more commonly known as Thoth
Toth was one of the most important gods
of ancient Egypt he was worshiped before
the age of the Pharaohs so before 5000
BC Toth was the god of magic wisdom and
the moon he was usually depicted as a
man with the head of an Ibis IBS Ibis
what I say Toth created writing and
hieroglyphics he wrote the Egyptian Book
of the Dead the Egyptians claimed he
invented science religion philosophy and
and of course Alchemy Greeks call him
the inventor of astronomy mathematics
civilized government and the alphabet
can't even overachieve it as Egyptian eh
well that's what's interesting Toth
wasn't actually a God he wasn't even
Egyptian he arrived in Egypt many
thousands of years ago and he brought
with them knowledge and wisdom from his
own country which is Toth is from
Atlantis
[Music]
Plato described Atlantis as being
divided into ten kingdoms each with his
own government its own rulers and its
own purpose one of these kingdoms was
the island of undal which was the
Atlantean Center of philosophy and
science those was born 36 000 years ago
anundal in the city of keora kaora was a
community of Scholars scientists and
Priests Toth was trained by his father
totemay who was a very important figure
in Atlantis topme was one of the
children of light who were an advanced
race that lived alongside humans the
children of light provided the human
race with science language and
eventually technology some have said
these beings were extraterrestrials or
the Anunnaki or both though the children
of light weren't gods they would appear
Godlike to any normal human but these
are mortal beings they're born and they
die just like we do but if he could die
I'm getting to it sorry sorry go ahead
like this story I thought you would
anyway though's father taught me was The
Keeper of the Great temple which means
he was a high priest who carried
messages to the human race from the
children of light wise will we with the
wisdom of the children of the like well
Among Us strong will we with the power
drawn from the Eternal fire and of all
these greatest among the children of men
was my father Pope May keepa of the
Great temple linked between the children
of Light Within the temple in the races
of men were inhabited from the ten
Islands
the ten kingdoms of Atlantis were
created by an entity named horlitt
sometimes called the dweller and Toth
spent many years with the dweller
learning the art of wisdom Toth excelled
in his studies and was finally invited
to the halls of amenti it's there where
Toth is given the key to life
immortality and he like the other
children of light can reincarnate every
hundred years but as an immortal Toth is
responsible for keeping the ancient
knowledge that he's been taught then a
great flood destroys Atlantis how long
ago was that thirteen thousand years ago
when was the youngest driest thirteen
thousand years ago
yet another flood myth takes place
during a period of time known as the
younger dryas every culture on Earth has
the same blood myth anyway in order to
preserve the knowledge and culture of
Atlantis Toth is one of the teachers
sent out to establish new colonies
around the world one of these colonies
is in South America another is in
Central America Toth travels to a land
the atlanteans call chem but we know it
as Egypt Toth took with him a tablet
carved out of green emerald though some
believe it might have been Crystal
others say the tablet was made of
oracalcum a valuable ancient metal that
according to Plato was mined in Atlantis
on this Emerald Tablet Toth wrote the
secrets of the universe including the
key to immortality this knowledge would
become the foundation for ancient
Egyptian Alchemy now for centuries toast
would reincarnate into different bodies
sharing his wisdom with a select few
usually he was born in Egypt but
sometimes his mission would take him to
other parts of the world and that takes
us to ancient Greece where the Emerald
Tablet makes its first appearance
[Music]
the Emerald Tablet also known as
tabulous margadina in Latin is only 24
stanzas of text but hidden within those
few stanzas is the secret to immortality
the tablet is said to have been written
by Hermes Tres Magistas who some say is
a combination of the Greek God Hermes
and the Egyptian god Toth or is a
Reincarnation of Toth himself Hermes
trezmagistus is the author of a group of
texts called the hermetica and from
these we get hermeticism a set of
spiritual Concepts and practices
characterized by a belief in the unity
of all things in the universe
hermeticism has influenced secret
societies like the Freemasons the
rosicrucians and the Order of the black
Sun the Hermetic Order of the Golden
Dawn is a secret society that emerged in
the late 19th century they used hermetic
principles in their ceremonies which
were said to be magic the order also
Drew on other esoteric Traditions
including Kabbalah and Tarot the
earliest known mention of the Emerald
Tablet comes from an Arabic text dated
1200 years ago but this text claims to
be a translation of a much older work
which is possibly a translation of an
even older text upon Discovery the
Emerald Tablet became one of the most
studied documents by Islamic and
European Alchemists it also became
popular with occultists who often used
the motto As Above So Below which is the
second verse of the tablet but these
were all just translations the original
tablet was lost then sometime in the
First Century A.D the philosopher
apollonius of Tiana was studying in the
city's Library when he came across a
mysterious book it was bound in green
leather and its Pages were made of a
material that he had never seen before
the book was written in a language that
he didn't recognize and its Pages were
filled with strange symbols and diagrams
Apollonia studied the book and realized
that it was a book of alchemy filled
with the secrets of the universe and the
hidden forces of nature determined to
uncover the mysteries of the book
Apollonia set out on a quest to find its
author after Allah long search he came
to a remote temple in the mountains
where he met an oracle who told him
where to look for answers apollonius was
given directions to a secret cave
underneath the statue of Hermes in Tiana
at the end of a dark whining passage
apollonius found the corpse of Hermes
trismic Estes sitting on a Golden Throne
still clutched in his withered skeletal
fingers Hermes had a Dusty book and a
tablet carved from a single piece of
translucent green stone apollonius took
the Emerald Tablet and the book and
sealed the cave he then Incorporated
these Newfound secrets of alchemy into
his own work but then the Emerald Tablet
was lost again again it's lost to have
tiny what's this thing well it was
pretty big almost four feet long and
about three feet wide
Giant tablet eh everyone who touches it
suddenly comes down with a case of the
Butterfingers it would seem so
apollonius wrote that he gave the tablet
to the Roman Emperor Hadrian who buried
it under his Palace but some think the
tablet was in the Library of Alexandria
when it burned Orr was taken by the
Knights Templar or it's in the Vatican
secret archives it's been said to have
ended up at just about every mysterious
place on Earth but in 1925 a man named
Dr Maurice Dorial had an idea the early
stories of the Egyptian godtoth talk of
him building the Great Pyramid of Giza
as a way to protect an ancient artifact
so Dr Dorial went to Egypt and explored
the area where he thought the Emerald
Tablet might be oh did he find it not
exactly
he found all ten
the tablets Dorial found were in the
possession of a mysterious group called
The Great White Brotherhood they
wouldn't allow Dorial to take the
tablets but they did let him translate
them a few years later in 1939 Dr Dorial
published his translation as a book The
Emerald Tablets of tothi atlantian his
translation confirmed that the tablets
were indeed written by Toth Dorial went
on to found the Brotherhood of the white
temple a religion that still exists and
has a following one of the main themes
of the book and of the Brotherhood of
the white temple is the concept of the
one thing the one thing is described as
the source of all creation and the
Ultimate Reality behind the physical
world it's said to be an energy that
permeates all things and is the essence
of all life the force is what gives a
Jedi his powers it's an energy field
created by all living things it
surrounds us and penetrates us it binds
the Galaxy together and we did a Star
Wars bit last week we can't go back to
that well so soon it was worth the shot
well the book also describes ancient
Technologies and hid knowledge it
suggests that ancient civilizations had
Advanced Technologies and knowledge that
have been lost over time for example the
book describes a device called the
Firestone which is said to have the
power to generate energy and manipulate
matter the book claims this technology
was used by ancient civilizations
including the atlanteans but it's being
suppressed but a large part of the book
covers Alchemy specifically transforming
base Metals into gold curing illness
granting immortality and achieving
Enlightenment but like the original
Emerald Tablet it was all allegory and
symbolism subject to many different
interpretations there are no clear
instructions the tablet doesn't tell us
what kind of materials we need to create
the Philosopher's Stone and even if they
did they don't tell us the process but
on March 11 2011 a mysterious book
suddenly appeared online it was called
The Book of Aquarius and this is what
was written on the first page the age of
Secrets is over there's no need for
mystical language or metaphor this book
retains no hidden meaning or codes
everything is stated plainly and
directly so what the hell is this mean
well this means that anyone who wanted
to create the Philosopher's Stone now
has a recipe to follow just like a
cookbook The Book of Aquarius looked
legit it's 165 pages and references 49
different alchemical texts that span a
thousand years it's a long difficult
process but anyone with the time and
patience could do it and some people did
and what's most amazing about the recipe
for the Philosopher's Stone is that it's
only one ingredient and we all have it
in us
what are you talking about what's the
one ingredient we need to live forever
well the one ingredient is um what urine
come on
some of the greatest Minds in history
have tried to find the secret of the
Philosopher's Stone when the Book of
Aquarius appeared on an online Forum in
2011 the anonymous author encouraged
everyone to spread it online for free he
wrote the purpose of this book is to
release one particular secret which has
been kept hidden for the last 12 000
Years the book of Aquarius contained
easy to understand step-by-step
instructions for how to create the
Philosopher's Stone which if created
properly would Grant you eternal life
the author of the book said that all the
old Alchemy texts using confusing
metaphors and symbolism was actually
done intentionally this was an early
disinformation campaign a way to keep
the recipe secret but still make it
accessible to Alchemists who knew how to
decipher the text and when the Book of
Aquarius was posted to an online Forum
it was ridiculed at first there was no
way you could achieve immortality with P
but throughout history Alchemists
actually used urine all the time the
16th century Swiss Alchemist paracelsis
clay find that life Essence was in Blood
and hair sweat and human waste the Book
of Aquarius says that the Philosopher's
Stone is this life energy concentrated
and purified this is the same energy you
take in when you breathe when you eat
and drink it's the energy that powers
all forms of life so it makes sense that
it would be found in urine ancient
Alchemists do this as well remember
earlier I mentioned the secret society
called the Hermetic Order of the Golden
Dawn it had a lot of famous members WB
Yates Aleister Crowley Arthur Conan
Doyle and a lot of other names that
you'd recognize their name Golden Dawn
is a reference to the only ingredient
used to make the Philosopher's Stone
golden as in the color and Dawn because
that's the best time of day to get it
you had got to be me nope but now what
the Book of Aquarius hitting the web all
the secret symbolism and Oaths of
secrecy were useless The Book of
Aquarius gave specific step-by-step
instructions on how to store boil the
still ferment and purify urine it would
take months or even years but eventually
a stone would start to form it was all
in the book how to do it what the
results should look like what the
process smells like nobody really tried
to make this crazy thing today
they sure did
shortly after the Book of Aquarius was
published the anonymous author set up a
website at the bookofaquarius.com there
you could of course download a free copy
of the book but also participate in a
forum where people would try to follow
the instructions of the book as closely
as possible and create their own
Philosopher's Stone and although the
stone only required one ingredient ankle
right the process for extracting your
life energy required patience even if
you did everything correctly it would
take between three and eight years to
finish the work and make a stone and
that's assuming you kept your materials
free from contamination controlled the
temperature and use the correct
equipment at the correct phase of
production a lot could go wrong yet a
small but determined group of people
were giving it their best shot the
recipe for creating the stone had two
major parts first you had to repeatedly
distill the urine and continually remove
the densest particles next you do it all
again but this time remove the lightest
particles which would be a form of salt
this first part would ideally take three
months but could often take up to a year
in the second part of the recipe you
combine the salt with the distilled
urine and put it on a low and continuous
heat you do that for over a year until
it putrifies and turns black and the
next part of the recipe wait what can
you not call it a recipe please it makes
it sound like he is supposed to eat it
well what
what when you're done with the process
you do eat it I'm gonna be sick what's
your problem you're swimming in half the
recipe right now it's the same thing
at bubbles I got filters besides I only
tinkling it back in a bowl I don't think
it matters
anyway you keep heating the black stuff
and eventually it turns white and then
you turn up the heat a little bit more
and the stone turns red and then you're
pretty much ready to go the book even
gives you some guidance on how much you
should um
can't on the Book of Aquarius forums a
community of amateur Alchemists emerged
even the author of the book was an
active member and would answer anyone
who had a question people were following
the process sharing tips and strategies
they would discuss how different foods
affected their Essence they even posted
pictures of their results this went on
for a few years long enough for at least
one person to succeed did somebody
actually get this crazy thing to work
well nobody knows because suddenly and
without warning The Book of Aquarius
website was gone
we covered a lot today the Egyptian god
Toth Atlantis the Emerald Tablet Hermes
trism Augustus apollonius of Tiana The
Book of Aquarius and how they all
connect to the Philosopher's Stone but
how much of the story is true well a lot
of it is but let's look at the parts of
the story that are questionable first
the Emerald Tablet is indeed a text
that's at least 1200 years old it is
considered one of the most important
documents in alchemy Isaac Newton and
many others were fascinated with it and
spent large parts of their life trying
to decode it but the Emerald Tablets
plural that's a different story all the
stuff about Atlantis comes from the book
The Emerald Tablets of Toth Theologian
by Dr Maurice Dorial and a lot of that
information is part of dorial's religion
the Brotherhood of the white temple the
Brotherhood really does exist it even
has a lodge in Colorado and Dorial has a
lot of followers you can find tons of
Articles and YouTube videos from people
who believe that Dorial was chosen to
deliver his message to the world
there is now look maybe Dorial really
did discover the tablets in Egypt and
translate them maybe he really is
helping people on their Journey to the
light of Truth as the Brotherhood claims
hey your tone is drifting at the sarcasm
territory but before you join this cult
religion there are a few things you
should know about Dr Maurice Dorial Dr
dorial's real name was Claude dawggins
and he wasn't a doctor of anything he
never graduated high school which is
amazing because he claimed that he was
able to read and write as soon as he was
born and was doing advanced mathematics
before the age of one yet no interest in
getting a GED yeah yeah I guess not so
no record of him receiving a doctorate
but there is record of him driving a cab
he drove a cab in Egypt oh he never went
to Egypt yeah but his passport verifies
this when he was confronted about the
passport problem Dorial AKA dawggins
said well they weren't physical travels
they were astral travels Doggins wrote a
lot about astral travels and other
paranormal phenomena he wrote about UFOs
alien attacks the nuclear war that he
predicted would happen in 1956 and he
wrote about human serpent hybrids living
in the Gobi desert people people yep hey
did you know you could buy a lizard
people love for no I file store use
promo code no merch plugs now
his followers will say all the things
that Dorial wrote were true the problem
is his stories were lifted from
prominent science fiction writers for
example dorial's Emerald Tablets book
has passages that match almost word for
word passages from the Necronomicon by
H.P Lovecraft ooh that was one of the
campfire stories I would read at camp
greenfoot Camp greenfoot oh yeah it was
a counselor there in the 80s kids love
me Lovecraft is kind of dark for kids no
you know didn't think so at the time but
I'm not gonna lie some of those kids
they grew up pretty weird anyway Dorial
also lifted ideas from the shaver
Mysteries which were popular in the
Sci-Fi pulp magazine Amazing Stories he
even wrote Into the magazine and Dorial
made all kinds of other wild claims as
most cult leaders do but there are too
many to list here Sally is a fruit well
I'm not saying that
but his wife did what at a public event
his wife called him out for lying and
cheating in front of a whole group of
disciples
no Furious yeah the quote-unquote cult
leader divorce made newspaper headlines
at the time now even with all this
information Dorial still has plenty of
Believers and the Brotherhood still
sells all of his books on their website
so the story of the original Emerald
Tablet that story is true the actual
tablet has never been found but the text
has been around for at least 1200 years
that's confirmed The Emerald Tablets by
Dorial well you can make your own
decision but to me it sounds like yet
another cult leader passing off science
fiction as his own writing to take
advantage of people for profit yeah nice
work if you can get it sure is look at
he's censored me of course I did their
lawyers watch this show you fair
enough so what about the Book of
Aquarius that one also sounds like
science fiction but turns out it's real
[Music]
ever since the Book of Aquarius website
was taken down there's not much
information about what happened to the
people who were trying to create their
own Stones one theory is that some
people are actually successful so either
they had the site taken down or the
Illuminati right some group of shadowy
Elites didn't want this information
public so they took down the website and
even though you can still download the
book from the internet archives you
can't view the messages on the message
board those have been scrubbed by
somebody another theory is that the Book
of Aquarius was a hoax but if that's
true it's a hoax that took a lot of
effort the book is 165 pages and the
author goes into meticulous detail and
It quotes from 49 different alchemical
texts ranging from the 20th century all
the way back to the 11th century many of
these texts are pretty obscure and hard
to find and no one has ever come forward
to take credit for writing it the Book
of Aquarius is probably not a hoax but a
book written by a passionate individual
who honestly believes they're sharing
the secret to creating a philosopher's
stone we can go yep there's actually a
well-documented case of an alchemist
attempting to create the Philosopher's
Stone from urine in 1669 German
Alchemist Hennig brand dedicated years
of his life to creating the stone he was
convinced urine was the way to do it and
he did everything that the Book of
Aquarius says to do after boiling and
Distilling 1500 gallons of his Essence
he ended up with a white waxy substance
that actually glowed in the dark he made
the stone no he accidentally discovered
phosphorus that to a 17th century
Alchemist this must have been amazing
here is a substance that was the product
of the human body that was glowing with
a life force LeBron kept the recipe
secret while he tried to create gold but
when he couldn't get that to work he
sold the recipe to another Alchemist as
for living forever well it's been
reported that hedick Bron did die but
nobody knows exactly when now of course
Legend says that he faked his death and
like Nicholas Flamel is still alive
today does that make sense to me if I
created the Philosopher's Stone I don't
think I'd ever tell would you now if you
want to try creating it the Book of
Aquarius is still available online and
linked below but I don't recommend it
boiling urine smells awful but that's a
small price to pay for immortality wait
how do you know it smells awful uh don't
worry about that now if you do decide to
try and create the Philosopher's Stone
do me a favor email me in about 600
years and we'll both have a good laugh
oh
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ there's
hacklefish and this has been the y-files
if you had fun or learned anything do us
a favor and like subscribe comment share
that stuff really helpful now they
learned some things today I agree I
think you think you apology actually oh
they're fine now like most topics we
cover on this channel today's was
recommended by you and if there's a
story that you'd like to see or learn
more about go to the yfiles.com tips
special thanks to our patrons who make
this channel possible you guys are
amazing and if you'd like to support the
channel and join this incredible
Community consider becoming a member on
patreon or join our Discord server or
grab something from the Wi-Fi store oh
yeah you could grab yourself a camp
green foot t-shirt right now already
that that was fast hey capitalism moves
quick belly that's gonna do it until
next time be safe be kind and know that
you are appreciated I gotta take a leak
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]